el presidente Jair bolsonaro ha dejado
Brasil para instalarse en Florida en los
Estados Unidos durante unos meses para
un periodo sabático son dos las razones
que le llevan a esa decisión no quería
entregar la banda presidencial a su
rival Luis Ignacio uroda Silva pero
también teme sorpreso porque a partir
del 1 de enero perderá la inmunidad y
hay varias acusaciones contra él entre
las cuales está divulgar noticias falsas
sobre el covid al asociar la vacuna al
sida poco antes de marcharse a bordo del
avión presidencial bolsonaro hizo su
última conexión en directo desde las
redes sociales y por fin condenó el
intento de ataque terrorista aquí en
Brasilia durante las navidades cuando la
policía encontró un camión bomba cerca
del aeropuerto pero se desmarcó de los
campamentos de bolsonaristas que desde
hace dos meses están protestando frente
a los cuarteles del ejército en varias
ciudades de Brasil contra victoria de
Lula la reacción a sus palabras de sus
seguidores ha sido contundente hemos
visto a muchos bolsonaristas
decepcionados incluso llorando que han
abandonado estas postaciones en las que
han estado incluso Debajo de la lluvia
en las últimas semanas ahora en Brasil
está todo listo para la investidura de
Lula que será el uno de enero hay mucha
seguridad aquí mucha policía lo hemos
comprobado hoy la plaza de los tres
poderes y se espera que todo pueda
proceder de una forma pacífica y sin
violencia